how's compress my name's welcome to the
scariest game the show where we try to
find scamper the first one is called
brighter day it's supposed to be a
horror game that takes takes place
during the bright day here we are okay
right we're going right at it
[ __ ] hell what do you want Jesus
Christ [ __ ] that [ __ ]
little little princess sakura-chan KY
jester sakura-chan nice and clean
bathroom nice tall ceiling got my drugs
okay I have my drugs
I can throw pills because why the [ __ ]
yeah
Oh her name is princess EXO La Fleur
great name well we better be going then
oh my god the noises alright shift to
run experience the healing power of the
monolith fantastic I don't know where
I'm Jose okay okay you know what I'm
gonna go this way
[ __ ] you why is this so creepy princess
eggs Olaf they're ours creepy things out
there let's try and throw the drugs at
the eye oh god I'm scared
but yeah I Tendo I can't go downstairs
[ __ ] sake the eyes are everywhere set
a pill oh my god what am i doing what do
I do with the drugs
maybe it's oh my god
[ __ ] hell what is this [ __ ]
the hell is this place creepy eyes eyes
and [ __ ] [ __ ] you it's terrifying
oh god more drugs in the card a Pokemon
card finally another perk a man can just
wash away the pain now I can see your
crying in the shower no one can see your
tears in the shower oh my god almost
full of drugs so much drugs you got to
[ __ ] cares of drugs I could finally
start dealing again Jesus Christ I'm so
confused
never been this confused in my life
Bruce I'm gonna get all the drugs and
then then get the [ __ ] out that's the
plan get all the drugs and get the [ __ ]
out exit how nice oh okay not nice not
nice not nice not nice at all girl oh
[ __ ] a dick out oh my god oh my god
please tell me they can't go in here
there's a ladder on the roof we need to
get to the roof Oh God Oh God
[ __ ] prince's saddle off I'm startled
you're not doing anything it is lay
there all day yeah
ah [ __ ] I can go out palaces oh my
god look at that face don't look at it
don't look at him don't look at him
don't look at him oh my god I can
distract them with the exit I need more
pills
I need my pills and Neema [ __ ] yo this
game is called the static speak my name
ah goddamn that [ __ ] ringtone today
will be a better day
well it sure as hell better be [ __ ]
hell I wake up early
3:22 who wakes up at 3 22
can I turn this [ __ ] off thank God
all right I gotta take a [ __ ] alright
IRAs an alga sob you look good tonight
alright here we go
got a pope really got a pope I ate way
too Mitch how do I eat breakfast I don't
even this my out why do I put that is
just a waste of electricity why did I
for this [ __ ] up
this is stupid I'll take my case just in
case I need them later - hidden doram
why am i obsessed with Bahamas
probable setting of painting
okay well it looks like a bad [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy
my focus focus focus and eat breakfast
let's grab some eggs ah
still empty I guess it's shrimp again
Wow
all right resent I don't want to do this
as much if you don't want to do this but
it's you or me who is an don't look at
me like that rosette you know [ __ ] you
the stabber lost all right what's my
next objective let's see you chat online
with friends yeah I'm not gonna share
with [ __ ] shrimps cuz shrimp so dog
my hope is online see a fairy 996 8 hi
handsome how are you doing I'm okay how
are you I'm horny press G to say you're
at Ferris everyone who believed in you
press H to say you can feel the atoms in
your body waking up I feel like H would
probably get me [ __ ] so I've gotta get
with age I just never mind
I'm touching myself do you want to see
press G to say you're about to do
something horrible press H to admit you
saw your reflection be decapitated with
a shovel
which one will get me laid first off I
don't want you to blame yourself and
with that gone I'm sorry I had to leave
you too please don't be mad at me that's
how we should have written I fix the
script you're welcome
holy [ __ ] I have a book about with
Uganda as the dumbest [ __ ] book ever
read
there you are my beautiful no one will
ever oh I tried to recreate it that's
kind of sad isn't it
I really try Oh Bengt are you still
alive what the [ __ ] man what are you
baked why did you eat this Tommy oh that
was good stuff son you waste good shrimp
oh I'm sorry it's not good enough for
you
[ __ ] fancy-pants God do you make me
sick
you make me what I [ __ ] [ __ ] in your
face oh I'm sorry
oh yeah you know what I'm gonna go and
kill myself how about that see you feed
you shrimp then [ __ ] decide what to
do with the man in the cage oh okay then
I guess you know what I've been harsh on
him I'll give him some shrimp and shove
it up his ass feel free
all right then
can I go to sleep now good night
everyone he's out wish I could just have
one more strip
except I love you said we'd get married
someday strip
why don't you love me back the static
speaks my name that was a weird [ __ ]
game I really enjoyed it those cool cool
creepy experience it shows that you
don't always need some jumpy scarce to
to freak you out for the last game we're
going to play the scariest game ever
scared it's called for some reason this
game is for you alright that was that
was the scariest game ever
Bruce check out the link in description
go vote for which game you thought was
scariest and by the end of this series
we'll finally found which one was the
scariest oh boy that sure was scary
anyway bros hope you enjoyed this
episode if you did that would be a great
time to drop a like and a comment about
how much you love anime tits in your
face and I will see you bros
exponent that's always stay awesome
press oh my god oh my god oh my god
simp I simply do something step back how
help